earlier today Apple fans were blindsided
by a terrible announcement the new
iPhone 7 won't have traditional
headphone jacks god damn it what the god
damaged Donna
[Applause]
this confirmed everyone's worst fears
that the iPhone would eliminate that
tight sweet headphone hole and replace
it with new wireless air pods that you
definitely won't lose in the cushions of
your couch they are to be fair including
a dongle that can adapt to the old
headphones but who wants to ruin their
slim new phone with some big fat dongle
that flaps around in the wind like an
asshole not me already got one of those
this new development comes in thank you
this new development comes in spite of a
petition at 300,000 irate iPhone users
signed to stop Apple from killing the
headphone jack here's the thought about
this uuu you could just not buy it you
don't have to on an optically your right
on the other hand you totally have to
buy it yeah I will comedians what's
another petition fans might sign against
Apple James I'm not a trump bam but I do
believe that we need to make cell phones
great again
yeah there should be a petition to ban
anybody with a cracked screen from
holding a baby my son almost drowned but
I stuck them in rice
[Applause]